Der Klimawandel ist da und extreme Wetterlagen
erwischen uns schon jetzt mit voller Breitseite.
Doch nicht nur das: Mit der Hitze kommen auch
die Menschenkiller Nummer 1 nach Deutschland,
subtropische und tropische Insekten.
Einer neuen Studie zufolge werden sich Moskitos
wie die Asiatische Tigermücke und die Gelbfiebermücken
in den kommenden 30 Jahren flächendeckend
in Deutschland ausbreiten.
Und die ersten sind schon da:.
Und wenn es noch heißer wird, dann wird es
noch gefährlicher.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Hier in Deutschland empfinden wir Mücken
bislang lediglich als lästig.
Doch dies könnte sich bald ändern, denn
es gibt nicht wenige Mücken, die folgenreiche
Tropenkrankheiten übertragen.
Malaria, Dengue, Zika und das West-Nil-Virus,
um nur einige Beispiele zu nennen.
Diese sind also lange nicht nur mehr lästig,
sondern sehr gefährlich.
Und die Erderwärmung begünstigt die Ausbreitung
genau solcher Mücken.
Und so finden die blutsaugenden Insekten in
vielen neuen Regionen dieser Erde jetzt nach
und nach hervorragende Lebensbedingungen.
Der Klimawandel macht es möglich.Vor allem
Europa, aber auch viele andere Regionen der
Welt werden in den nächsten Jahren von den
Stechtieren heimgesucht werden.
Schon 2017 und 2018 wurden im Süden von Deutschland
Asiatische Tigermücken aufgespürt.
Einer aktuelle Hochrechnung eines internationalen
Forschungsteams zufolge könnten dann knapp
eine halbe Milliarde Menschen mehr solchen
Tropenkrankheiten potentiell zum Opfer ausgesetzt
werden als bislang.
Dabei geht es vor allem um die Erkrankungen,
die die Gelbfiebermücke “Aedes aegypti”
und die Tigermücke “Aedes albopictus”
übertragen.
In der aktuellen Untersuchung werden verschiedene
Szenarien bezüglich der globalen Erwärmung
analysiert.
Konkret gelang dies durch die Auswertung von
Daten aus 35 Jahren Feldforschung.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Forscher Moritz
Krämer: “Durch die Kombination von Daten
zur Ausbreitungsgeschichte von Mückenarten,
zu Populationsbewegungen und klimatischen
Faktoren konnten wir die Zukunft dieser krankheitsübertragenden
Moskitos vorhersagen" Und das Ergebnis ist
alarmierend.
Denn selbst, wenn der Klimawandel noch maximal
gebremst werden kann und die Pariser Ziele
und die Zwei-Grad-Grenze sicher eingehalten
werden, steht fest: Sowohl Gelbfiebermücken
als auch Tigermücken werden sich zukünftig
in Deutschland ausbreiten.
Dem internationalen Forschungsteam zufolge
werden die Tigermücken hier schon in 30 Jahren
heimisch sein - und zwar im Sommer ein bis
drei Monate lang.
Auf ihrem Weg in Richtung Norden dringen die
Tiere der Berechnung zufolge 150 Kilometer
pro Jahr vor.
Die Gelbfiebermücken dagegen brauchen etwas
länger und werden sich wohl erst einmal in
der Türkei und Italien ausbreiten, ehe sie
nach Deutschland kommen.
Dort werden sie sich vor allem im Südwesten
und Nordosten, also in Baden-Württemberg
und Brandenburg, heimisch fühlen - und das
auch nur etwa einen Monat lang.
Auch wenn das auf den ersten Blick vielleicht
harmlos klingen mag, ist das eine große Bedrohung
für uns.
Denn laut der Experten könnten sich die Tiere
explosionsartig vermehren und zu einem akuten
Ausbruch von Krankheiten führen.
Und das ist ja wie bereits angesprochen nur
das harmloseste Szenario.
FALLS die Temperaturen aber in Zukunft weiter
ansteigen, bedeutet das für die Moskitos,
dass sie vor allem in Europa paradiesische
Bedingungen vorfinden.
Hier werden die Tiere auch die meisten ihrer
neuen Opfer vorfinden: Je nach Zeitraum und
Szenario sind es bei den Gelbfiebermücken
bis zu 470 Millionen potentiell neu zu infizierende
Menschen.
Dazu kommen noch einmal bis zu 440 Millionen
potentielle Opfer der Tigermücken.
Laut der aktuellen Studie könnten unter extremen
Klimaszenarien bis zum Jahr 2080 also eine
Milliarde Menschen mit einer durch Mücken
übertragenen Krankheit konfrontiert werden
- Viele davon im westlichen Europa.
Fest steht also: Tropenkrankheiten sind schon
lange nicht nur mehr das Problem ferner Weltregionen.
Andere Regionen der Erde dagegen bieten dann
nicht mehr so ideale Lebensbedingungen für
die Moskitos.
In den meisten Gegenden von Afrika, im Amazonasbecken
und Südostasien würde es nämlich zu heiß
für sie werden, WENN der Klimawandel weiter
so voranschreitet.
Die Infektionsraten in diesen Regionen würden
langfristig wohl sinken, denn die Mücken
vertragen nur Temperaturen bis zu 29 Grad
Celsius.
Wenn es wärmer ist, gelingt die Weitergabe
von Krankheitserregern nicht mehr gut.
Doch Gesundheitsexperten warnen, dass dies
keinesfalls ein Grund zum Aufatmen ist.
So zum Beispiel der US-Wissenschaftler Colin
Carlson: “Jedes Szenario, in dem es zu heiß
für die Weitergabe des Dengue-Erregers wird,
enthält andere und ähnlich gefährliche
Veränderungen im Gesundheitssektor”.
So oder so führen höhere Temperaturen als
zu mehr gefährlichen Krankheiten, Gut ist
das also alles nicht.
Aber wir können jetzt konkret etwas tun:
Wir können am 26.
Mai zur Europawahl gehen und zweitens genau
die Partei wählen, die die Standpunkte vertritt,
die jetzt wichtig sind und unser Überleben
sichern.
Es ist die letzte Wahl, nach die Politik noch
etwas ändern kann.
Und wir sind diejenigen, die entscheiden!
Also laßt es uns tun!
Hashtag #diesmalwahleich Europawahl 2019:
Alles, was man wissen muss von MrWissen2go
Anklicken und anschauen würde ich mal sagen!
Wir sehen uns am 26.
Mai im Wahllokal.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!